pression sanitaires se fait fortement
sentir sur les hôpitaux et la médecine
de ville et la dynamique épidémie qui
est forte
il s'agit de la nièvre du rhône et de
l'aube pour ces trois départements
après concertation avec les élus mais
aussi avec les services de l'état avec
les établissements de santé
il est apparu indispensable d'amplifier
les mesures de protection
à l'instar de ce qui a été mise en
oeuvre la semaine dernière dans les
départements concernés en ile-de-france
dans les hauts de france et en normandie
à compter de ce vendredi minuit et pour
quatre semaines donc dans ces trois
départements le couvre-feu continue de
s'appliquer
de 19 heures à 6 heures les
rassemblements en extérieur ne doivent
pas dépasser six personnes les
déplacements sont autorisés de 6 heures
à 19 heures lorsque c'est dans un rayon
inférieur à 10 km sans attestation sans
limitation de durée
on vous demande d'avoir sur vous un
justificatif de domicile comme une pièce
d'identité entre 6 heures et 19 heures
si vous dépassez 10 km depuis votre
domicile mais également de 19h à 6h
cette fois ci quelle que soit la
distance
vous devrez avoir une attestation
dérogatoire les déplacements inter
régionaux sont interdits sauf motif
impérieux ou professionnels les
commerces de première nécessité reste
ouvert les écoles maternelles et
primaires et les collèges restent
ouverts tandis que les lycées passent
tous en 2011 enfin les lieux de culte
restent ouverts ce sont donc dans ces
trois départements les mêmes mesures de
freinage fortes qui sont mises en place
que celle annoncée dans les autres
départements concernés la semaine
dernière